Yes.
Hello my name is bob hopkins.
I'm a long time resident of nim and i've.
Came here primarily as a political
gesture and as a consequence i continue
that these lines of interest within them
and i've been involved over the years
with nima news very active within the
nimbin community school in the main
hall committee currently secretary
and public officer of the
human environment center.
Plus a few others various
organizations associated with that.
And presently i'm working at
the women recycling center.
You.
Know look there have been times when i
possibly could have fitted that bill
but one doesn't maintain these particular.
Titles are too long.
When i first came to him and here the year
before the festival happened so i nym
and tended to stand out in my mind i was
working for a chap in sydney who wanted to
set up a primal therapy
centre in the country.
He was looking for undeveloped land.
The real estate agents in lismore all
said undeveloped land dirty land you want
names and so i came to them and here and
one hundred seventy two. It was very much.
Just a really.
Forgotten little town it was a town
in the middle of a rural decline.
Most of the shops were either empty
or being lived in as residents
the farming community was very
poor rundown people living on not a great
deal of income how there were farms for
sale all over the place.
I travelled on from their return to
lismore the next year as a student of the
teachers college. And.
As fate would have it.
I was right on the spot
when the festival happened.
Well yeah but it's interesting in a sort
of historical perspective we my wife
and myself were both
pretty young at. Right.
My son was born on the second
day of the festival. And.
My wife and i were both pretty young at
that time pretty unsure about doing
a home birth by ourselves we.
From the point of view
of the fact that birth
and beyond as a home birth
organizations existed now.
In nimbin for the last 17 years.
It's interesting too it
makes it an interesting.
Time capsule.
We tried to get a doctor or a midwife at
that time to attend the birth
but found it very difficult so
we went to the northern star
and advertised for a
doctor or a midwife and at
that stage they wouldn't accept the ad
because it was considered to be an obscene
ad. It's interesting. Now i mean.
In light of all the changes that
have gone on around the area
that these it gives a an interesting.
Sense of the passing of
time and the changes
that have been wrought by this society.
The first of all affected the
town in a pretty fundamental way.
Because what it meant was
that the people a lot of the people
who came here decided to stay.
It's a beautiful area land
was cheap land was plentiful
and the feeling was so
good at the festival
that a lot of people wished to maintain
that sense of satisfaction.
The festival itself was also conceived
as an ongoing festival it wasn't
it. It was part of a series
of biennial festivals
that were run by the national union
union of australian university students
and were arts oriented what
had happened in the past was
that festivals tended to set up for a
couple of weeks people would hang their
paintings a few drama
activities would go on.
But this way and then at the end
everyone would pack up and go away
but with this one. It was conceived
as an ongoing festival of lifestyles
and that's exactly what happened
and the way i see it is
that the festival has
never really stopped.
It's been an ongoing 20 year
exercise in people seeking to
bring about a fundamental change
in lifestyles community politics.
The way that people relate to each other
and to the environment
particularly and it still goes on.
It's still happening all
the time it's got a.
A remarkable sort of history
of achievements behind it.
Now in things as diverse as well.
Birth and beyond popularizing home birth.
And empowering women along the way the
changes in the multiple occupancy laws
that were one of the first changes
in tenure for a very long time.
The environmental political through
us that came from here that started.
And culminated in the training forest
protest the manatee forest protests
that just went on to other areas as
people realized the environmental
imperatives.
The whole turn ative energy
lobby is been particularly
persistent here which is resulted in the
formation of the rainbow power company.
The music
that has come out of here has
been at times most particularly
nimbin which is again reflected the attitudes
in the lifestyle through the music.
Idea what else is.
Happened over here over the last 20 years.
What is particular about and him and.
Is a a larrikin a particularly
larrikin australian
tendency to
seek to go for what. People consider
to be appropriate within themselves.
In a way that's full of
a combination of humor.
Political confrontation.
That are reflected a creative urge
that was most manifest in the
culture through the music in the
1970s music was a real powerful cultural
force it's become absorbed more
and more by the industry over
the years but the music in them
and has remained so there's always been.
Within the within nimbin.
A tendency to.
Express the you earnings for community
for the the magic of life for
an earth based spirituality
through the music.
You know it's not really my forte
but.
A lot of people have moved on.
For a lot of different reasons.
Out of frustration maybe
that they haven't achieved what they thought
they were going to are maybe they've
found that their.
Their actual life doesn't necessarily
correspond with the original dream.
But a lot of people have stayed.
The communities of continue to grow and
strengthen and expand and developing.
In ways that serve a particular need
of the people who are here for me.
Nimbin was a political possibility
or it offered the opportunity for a
political possibility that we touched upon.
I guess in the 60s during the times
of the vietnam conflict and all
that was associated with that
and it seemed as though nimbin was a place
where it was possible to actually create
some sort of new society which was based
upon this new alternative way of thinking.
And it does it offers these possibilities
it continues to offer these possibilities.
Because niman is a media name nationally.
People will notice things
that come out of nimbin.
The initiatives in all realms of sort
of political and community life.
The ability to meet people who are interested
in working in the same areas as you
out of a particular need for instance through
the community school in other areas.
It was difficult to establish systems
of alternative schooling because of the
small numbers of people in
nimbin with the prevailing
social situation which didn't allow a
great deal for the children of the
new settlers the tendency to
want to create an expression of
an alternative education system was
able to succeed simply because of the.
Large numbers of people who were
in the area and who desired this.
Like a lot of other things.
Society has changed over the years since
then and a lot of the initiatives
that was started at the community school
have now been absorbed into the central
school system.
And while the community school still
manages to exist it doesn't have the same
support
that it once did have this could be
a combination of prevailing changes
in people's attitude toward schooling
but i think to a large extent it's it's
come about as a consequence of the changes
that have been forged
by comparison with the prevailing systems
or by the the prevailing system looking
at what we were doing at the community
school
and altering their approach in order
to accommodate more the alternative.
The alternative education through us.
20 years is a long time.
A lot of changes happen in 20 years 20
years ago women weren't allowed in public
bars.
But society has undergone a
huge transformation during
that period of time organic agriculture
is now been recognized as being.
An almost imperative for
australian farmers. The senses.
I'm environmental imperatives
of also changed.
Nimbin as almost. Bored about.
A. Women as.
Women as manifested.
What it set out to do.
In the sense of putting a series of particular
issues into the public consciousness.
This is where the challenge
lies for them and.
To be able to look at the next 20 years
and lay down a vision that will hold for.
That will in 20 years time.
Be considered as being pertinent
and fundamental to nature of
society. But there is also a longer.
Aim that is there the
original aquarius festival.
Concentrated on a sense of tribes and
community in relation to the environment
and this is one of the things that
continues to attract me here and.
And what i see is happening is
that there is a particular culture being
formed for the earth to be sustainable.
It needs a sense of tribalism of people who
have grown up in a particular area who
are committed to living in a particular
area who get to know the area intimately
who forged. An ongoing.
Culture that takes into account
the area in which you live.
And i guess the in the long run the value
of newman will be seen. After
a two or three generations.
And it's only then really that.
Name and will be able to be
seen whether or not we're.
We've created a society
that is equal to the task the 20
year periods are useful in so far as
that they do provide a measuring
point of how far we've come.
But there is still the challenge
there for us to continue to put into
effect.
Whatever the vision is
that any one particular point of time so
much time is spent just holding ground
against the forces that are out there
that would potentially
overrun this point of view
that exists here in and
so as a consequence.
There are a lot of areas of social life
that a possibly lacking
in terms of the vision.
We've currently got the situation in town
where people are getting upset about the
state of.
Street behaviour
and drug related issues
and this is an area where which
i see is very pertinent to
the whole idea of nimbin
it seems fundamental to me
that no needs to rise to this
task confront the problem
of drugs in this society
and look at it in a new way implement new
directions rather than resorting to.
The old ways but it's very difficult
to step outside the dominant.
Thinking forms and
and actually implement change a change
that i would. In relation to
the to the drug issues in.
What we need is a a radical
reappraisal of the
drug situation how it affects us to
look at what it's doing to our society
and trying to create some
new form of approach
to the whole issue of drug use.
To do this we really need to step outside.
The whole of the dominant society
and forget the particular laws.
And create almost in a theatrical form
a new scenario a new paradigm for
possibility marijuana has been
associated with nimbin pretty much
right from the start as it was a
substance
that was taken up by the early hippies
and it was one of those it
has become a sacrament.
In those early days it still
does have this aspect about it
but what's happened over
the course of time is
that the price for this particular
substance has risen alarmingly
and because it has such a cash value.
It was one of the first things that people
stopped sharing where they were able.
To reenter into the consumption
of a society without
having to commit a large slice of
your life to working in offices
or working for corporations
or working in business
and commerce
and although it is seen to be
part of the freedom of nimh
and it is part of the reason why
niman is so in the seeds of its own
destruction in this to me just
pinpoint even more directly
the imperative for change
in this direction.
Within the drug issue
particularly at the moment in nim
and vast sums of money.
At the moment in and
large amounts of money.
Transferred between people
in the sale of marijuana.
None of this money returns itself to the
general community it goes always to
individual people. If in them
and we could regulate the sale of
marijuana in much the same way
that it happens the best model.
For where it is happening is in holland
where marijuana has a sort of quasi legal
stage as marijuana in holland
has a quasi legal status
where its sold in coffee shops its tax.
And the responsibility is on
the actual seller to make sure
that they're they take
responsibility for the
fact that they're involved in
selling an intoxicating substance.
If we were able to do the same thing
in nimbin we would have the people who
sorry. Let's just give us
scenario of a possible change.
If we had the rainbow cafe for
instance selling pot over the counter.
Then.
What we could do would be to undercut the
street price which would at limit the
hustle
that happens on the street would eliminate
the competitiveness of the violence.
It would take away the possibility for
the sort of parasitical chemical.
Heroines be.
Cocaine sellers
that are attracted by the the large
amounts of money by the illegality
by the fact
that there is an element of opposition
to the laws. And these
people have been bleeding.
The community dry.
If we had the rainbow cafe selling it.
Then they could it would
be i conceive of if the
rainbow cafe was selling
pot over the counter.
Then they would take on a responsibility
for administering the whole scene.
It would be up to them
to make sure that their.
Aren't the sort of congestion or that
there is in the sort of congestion
that exists in front of the rainbow cafe
the hustling the dealing that upsets
and outrages tourists
visitors locals alike
at the moment.
Alcohol is sold without any
responsibility being placed on.
The dispensers of alcohol to
really look after the people
that the alcohol affects
that they sell to i would say
that pubs should be able to
or should be made to provide child care
centers social workers people who just
mingle with the crowds make sure
that nobody who is looking
like they're becoming drunk
and becoming a problem to
themselves and to the society.
Should not be allowed to procure
any more alcohol in the same
way i apply the same line of
reasoning to marijuana sales the
people whose dispense the drugs
should be made to be to be
held responsible for the consequences of
what goes down following the marijuana
sales at the moment though because the
whole thing has an illegal status.
It's outside the realm of
society to really regulate. We.
You can have the police come
in and pick off a few dealers
but by the time
that their work their way through the
mountain of paper the fingerprinting.
Identification the photos.
Another two people could easily have
joined the street sellers by that.
Time
and at the end of the day the people who've
been arrested are just back on the streets
and ealing again. It's just that
the the war on drugs approach.
Hasn't worked in any country in the world.
In fact it's been
counterproductive in the same way
that it's been counterproductive here.
There's a disproportionate sense of
values being put down to the young
people.
A week's work and maybe we'll
do three hundred dollars
but announce a pot can
potentially year old you 400
or 500 dollars.
It's promoted.
Suspicion between people because
of the fact that your own.
Pot is likely to be ripped
off. Sale. On the streets.
There's no way you can trace
it there is no protection
that you have so people tend to
become suspicious of everyone.
Paranoid potentially even sort of
heading in the direction of taken
violent measures to protect their crops
these are the drug problems for me.
Rip offs are a big drug problem.
Not necessarily the the street
scene which in a lot of cases
doesn't necessarily relate to drugs
but it's associated with drugs because of
the types of people who come looking for
an easy way to make money an easy
society where things are a bit more
open and tolerated than any
other parts of australia
that i've encountered.
And nimbin.
Regularly used to hold these anti-heroine
meetings as heroin as sort of risen from
time to time into a state of prominence
and pretty widespread
use throughout the town
and public meetings have been held at two
or three year intervals at which time it
was more of an opportunity for people to
vent their anger their frustration.
Generally to attack the police
for not doing enough attack
indiscriminately all users.
No matter what they were using it
did nothing really to bring about a
sense of progress
or harmony for myself i started to notice
that people started to believe what others
said about their particular habits so
marijuana users tended to
actually become to feel
that they were somehow rather
the outcasts of society
that they were criminal it diminished
their own sense of self-esteem their own
sense of being their own
sense of value in life
and so i figured that the time
had come when i just had to try
and bring about a change because the more
that people felt victimized by the the
anti-drug feelings.
The less that they were
likely to play an active.
Role in determining the future of
their own society there was more.
They were more likely
to keep out of society.
Try and.
Guard their sources of income through
growing pot which really didn't
do a great deal towards
making this a better society
or a better community
to live in. And so i.
I stepped out from the
the cover of anonymity
to take on the drug laws which
in itself is pretty fascinating
because the whole nature of
drug use in society is has
implications and replications right
throughout so many strata of life.
I stood for parliament last year as being
on a i stood for parliament last year on
a drug reform ticket. Ok. Yeah.
I maintained.
After the last big heroin meeting which was
held in 1988 i formed a group here cool
nearly normal nimbin which
was a bit of a pun based.